A really good scream is a beautiful thing,
evolutionarily speaking.
It can cause wide-reaching results, and when
paired with a threat?
Ohhhhh man.
Fear can set off what’s called a defense
cascade -- a set of behaviors that cause you
to... run or defend yourself… - freeze because
you’re so scared… - or keep you from shouting
or moving at all! - sometimes it can cause
you to fall over - or even faint to protect
yourself!
Seriously, fear is really powerful.
The source of this emotional response is buried
deep in your brain; in a set of neurons called
the amygdala.
The fear can be emotional like abandonment,
or from physical danger like an attack.
But it can also be triggered by the sound
of screams.
And, new research has found just what about
a scream triggers your amygdala the best (or
worst)?
Screams, according to the paper, are a “unique
signal” and exploit distinct features not
used by regular speech!
When you hear voices, your brain processes
them -- “Do I know that man or woman?”
“How old are they?”
“Are they emotional?”
Screams?
Nuh-uh.
They go right from ear to amygdala.
BAM.
For the first time, the study characterized
the scariness of screams, by their roughness.
<pause>
Roughness, is a measure of modulation.
Think of alarm sounds, rougher ones are scarier,
like klaxons or alarm sounds.
If someone screams, you can hear that modulation
-- that’s like a vocal strobe light!
You can’t ignore it!
The “acoustic roughness,” they found,
“selectively activates the amygdala” triggering
fear and danger processing.
Fear feels different from other emotions.
And this is (partly) why.
Without it, we wouldn’t’ve made it this
far in our evolution.
Our brain processes screams differently from
other auditory communications.
As animals, we share this fear response with
other creatures, but as humans?
We can sometimes get stuck in this cascade.
Re-playing the fear again and again in our
minds…
By learning about how fear works we can help
people suffering trauma overcome it with therapy.
It’s amazing that all this comes back to
two little bits of neuron deep in our ancient
brains.
Happy Halloween everyone!
Special thanks to our sponsor for this episode,
Domain.com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 20% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Hey you!
Take a sec and subscribe.
Don’t be afraid.
Clowns!
Are you scared yet?
Why would they even be scary?
Natalia has the science, here.
Final fun fact: these fear emotions were first
analyzed by Darwin in 1872.
He recognized we have emotions to adapt to
our world, just like lower animals do!
Love that guy.
Thanks for watching!